En junio son las elecciones europeas,
unas elecciones que inciden y mucho
sobre nuestras vidas.
Y es que como país hemos cedido soberanía Nacional
a 1 proyecto de construcción común,
la Unión Europea.
Esto no es malo,
al contrario,
en 1 sistema con potencias mundiales mastodónticas,
está bien que tengamos 1 proyecto europeo
que sirva de contrapoder,
que defienda
1 modelo de sociedad como son las sociedades europeas,
con grandes avances sociales
y 1 Gran estado de bienestar.
No obstante, como ciudadanía no paramos de recibir
mensajes
contradictorios y negativos sobre este proyecto.
Por 1 lado, la de los cortopensantes
que creen que a España le iría mejor,
aislada y de espaldas a la Unión Europea,
que funcionaríamos mejor como país,
ya vimos durante 40 años de dictadura
lo que supone vivir aislados del Mundo.
Nos convertimos en 1 0 a la izquierda,
en 1 sociedad atrasada y ahogada en miseria.
Desde luego esa no es la vía.
Por otro lado,
la ciudadanía percibe que Europa le queda muy lejos,
que los tejemanejes de la actividad
política Europea no responden a su realidad social
y en este sentido puede que tengan parte de razón.
Está claro que se realiza 1 enorme labor
para introducir las reivindicaciones del Pueblo
español en Europa,
y esto lo hemos traducido en mejoras reales,
como la reciente mejora de los permisos retribuidos
o las garantías de protección de datos que logramos
Gracias a la Unión Europea.
Pero también tenemos esa otra Europa,
la de los lobbies,
Europa de los Intereses o interesados
que presionan a naciones
enteras para bloquear avances sociales.
El ejemplo más claro y actual de esto es la ley Rider.
Esta directiva ha sido bloqueada
porque estos intereses Han sabido tocar
a Francia y Alemania.
Cuando grabamos este vídeo estaba bloqueado.
Finalmente ha sido aprobado
porque Estonia y Grecia Han dado su apoyo.
Pero la actitud de Francia y Alemania
con los lobbys sigue siendo lamentable.
Estos 2 países no Han pensado en el Rider,
no Han pensado en el trabajador
que está puteado en la calle,
sino que se Han quedado con la versión del lobby
de presión de las plataformas de reparto, Uber,
globo, etc. es decir, se Han entregado a los poderosos.
Si queremos 1 proyecto de Europa,
que la ciudadanía entienda y se identifique con él,
hay que acabar con la política de alturas,
con la demoqueta y despacho.
Hay que acabar con el lobismo.
Hay que bajar Europa al terreno,
que cada ciudadano y ciudadana sepa y sienta
que puede y debe construir este proyecto.
La Primera cita para apropiarnos de ese
proyecto de Europa
la tenemos 09 de junio.
En las elecciones europeas
enviemos el mensaje de que queremos 1 Europa social,
1 Europa al servicio del Pueblo y no de las élites.
Haz tuya Europa